we're going to dive straight in with our
main story this week as it concerns a
topic that's been at the forefront of
the news over the past year tonight
inflation nation inflation's grip on
american consumers not letting up it's
called lunchflation boozeflation milk
flation meat flation is rocking the
nation okay first a big enthusiastic
nope to the word medflation which sounds
less like an economic phenomenon more
like a slang term for a boner it is
honestly hard to think of a more
unpleasant portmanteau than meat flakes
and aside from maybe snot which combines
the words sneeze and fart or ronzo which
would obviously be the celebrity couple
name if ron howard ever [ __ ] gonzo the
muppet
as you undoubtedly know the us is
experiencing the highest inflation of
the past 40 years and despite initial
hopes that it would be temporary prices
are still going up over the past year
food is up 10.4 percent electricity is
up 13.7
and gasoline is up 59.9
so to be honest it's probably a good
idea to start making your gasoline at
home in the morning instead of getting
an expensive cup of it on your way to
work
and in some cases companies have tried
to hide inflation by keeping their
prices the same but reducing the size of
their products it's called shrink
flation and news outlets love to cover
this usually with the help of what seems
to be the one go-to expert on the topic
there's almost no category of product
except eggs maybe that hasn't been
downsized over the past years consumer
advocate ed dwarski is publisher of
mouseprint.org chris 3d
white went from 4.1 ounces to 3.8 ounces
apple cinnamon cheerios went from 20.1
ounces to 19 ounces it's still called
family size the family must have gotten
smaller here you've got two bottles of
gatorade and these have just changed in
the past few months this one is the old
32 ounce one this one is four ounces
less they said they made it easier to
grip you know give me a break
yeah
you tell them ed
i love everything about that man from
his website
mouseprints.org which is somehow not an
online literary journal for writers who
happen to be rodents to his electrifying
delivery of the word eggs to his
utter refusal to tolerate even the
slightest amount of [ __ ] from
gatorade but
whether it's inflation shrink-flation or
meat-flation rising prices are clearly a
problem although hourly earnings were up
5.1 percent over the past year overall
wages fell by 3.6 percent when adjusted
for inflation and for those on fixed
incomes or tight budgets like students
and retirees inflation is especially
difficult to handle and can amount to a
life overhaul patty byther just
unretired and got ready for her new
part-time job i thought i was done i had
worked it all out financially that you
know i could afford it with prices
soaring her retirement lasted 10 months
these are my fuel bills in 13 months it
went up 150
correct my safety net is just gone when
do you see yourself retiring for real i
don't really see a time when i'll be
able to retire again or entirely again
which is
sort of annoying and sad
yeah that is putting it lightly it must
be so frustrating to retire think you're
done and then have to go back to work
that is the absolute worst case scenario
of retirement other than of course
moving to florida so
given that it is hurting so many people
right now tonight let's examine
inflation what caused it what we've done
to address it so far and what could
happen next and let's start with how
exactly we got here because you've
probably heard a lot of explanations
flying around this is biden inflation a
39-year high created by joe biden make
no mistake inflation is largely the
fault of putin the supply chain is the
catalyst at the end of the day inflation
is not caused by the billback better or
the bipartisan bill it's caused by
corporate greed yeah there has been a
flurry of finger-pointing with many
tending to place the blame on whatever
they were already mad at with some
democrats blaming corporate greed
republicans blaming joe biden biden
blaming putin and your dog presumably
blaming the vacuum cleaner and
here is the interesting thing aside from
the dog they're probably all at least a
little bit right because the truth is
there is no one cause of inflation at
the best of times it involves a
multitude of factors and the situation
that we're in right now has been an
unprecedented perfect storm and to
understand that storm it might actually
help to pause for a moment to talk about
the mechanics of inflation
very basically it happens whenever there
is too much demand for too little supply
if people have lots of money to spend
they usually want to buy more stuff but
if there is not enough stuff to go
around then the price of that stuff goes
up i'll give you an example let's say
that every single person in america
suddenly wins the lottery and everyone
now has 40 million dollars to spend what
are they going to do well i would assume
that they do what i would which is
immediately by this 1500 emeralds patina
fountain statue of a frog spreading its
unnaturally long legs in a manner that
seems offensive but i'm not exactly sure
to who now by the way the frog comes in
two sizes large and giant now
obviously if you win the lottery you are
springing for the giant one but here is
the problem there are currently only
three of them left in stock so the
statues are likely to get more expensive
because everyone suddenly wants one as
they all have more money to spend but
there are only three left basically high
demand not enough supply and that's how
we get frog flation so too much money
chasing a limited supply of goods can
lead to inflation and some on the right
have seized on the too much money part
of that idea to suggest that inflation
is really just down to one thing when
you put six trillion dollars of fiscal
stimulus into the economy as president
biden and democrats did last year you're
going to end up with big time inflation
the march stimulus package literally
manufactured inflation this inflation is
caused by democrat policies didn't just
happen this is the democrat tax on the
middle class wow that is some pretty
heavy fire there calling something a tax
on the middle class is one of the best
ways to make it look bad just after
calling it a close associate of prince
andrew
blaming biden's stimulus package has
become a common refrain on the right
when discussing inflation and the
reality is there is a kernel of truth to
it thanks to the pandemic era stimulus
bills people did have more cash on hand
but that is not the only reason as
strange as it sounds many people saved
money during the early days of the
pandemic simply because we were all
stuck at home by one estimate households
actually accumulated two and a half
trillion dollars in excess savings
during the pandemic and to the extent
that people were spending money it
mostly wasn't on services like flights
or hotels or restaurants instead it went
to goods like furniture appliances or i
don't know some steamy watercolor rat
erotica i'm just describing what most
people did in 2020
and what's more the notion that our
economy would be fine if not for biden's
stimulus completely ignores what it
would have looked like without it
because it not only protected low income
workers who were in real trouble it also
helped us avoid a covert induced
financial crisis and while with
hindsight most economists would say that
we could have made it more targeted and
precise so that we didn't increase the
money supply any more than we absolutely
had to it is very important to note that
according to one estimate without the
american rescue plan the economy would
have come close to suffering a
double-digit recession in the spring of
2021 so two things are likely true here
the government stimulus did contribute
to inflation but
it was also a necessary intervention and
the much bigger point is inflation
clearly isn't just about the stimulus at
all after all it's not just a problem
here in the u.s britain and germany have
seen inflation rates hit four decade
highs and in seven eastern european
nations it's now expected to surge past
double digits and in japan it had
particularly dramatic consequences
we're at an aquarium in hakone the
effects of inflation can be felt here
too is that i know with the rising price
of feed they've chosen to use the
cheaper mackerel
how are the penguins reacting to the new
feed
[Music]
she tries to coax it to eat
the penguin doesn't like it no
no it does not and i do not blame it i
love absolutely everything about that my
new favorite genre of new segment is now
footage of what appears to be a large
flightless bird being a massive [ __ ]
which
now that i say it out loud would be a
pretty accurate title for this show but
also remember demand is only one side of
this equation the other side is supply
and to quote my therapist let's come
back to that frog spreading its leg
statue because
in that scenario where everyone won the
lottery if there happened to be enough
frog statues for everyone to buy then
there wouldn't be any imbalance between
supply and demand and prices would
remain stable but remember there are
only three giant statues left in stock
and if for whatever reason they can't
make any more the price of the remaining
statues will then go up especially
because there aren't actually three of
them left anymore because i have one and
it's right over here
look at it
look at my beautiful frog statue
and crucially
crucially what that means is there are
now only two of the frog statues left
except to be honest there aren't two
because i have another one as well that
is right over there
look at my second frog statue what an
absolutely perfect pair and what that
means is that the last remaining frog
statue is going to be worth an absolute
fortune which to be honest is very good
news for me because i did get that one
as well here it is
i'm rich
i've got all the frogs i'm calling the
frog statue market i am good at business
come on
the larger macro economic point that i'm
making is demand is certainly a factor
but a smaller supply also leads to
inflation and generally speaking we've
had diminished and disrupted supplies of
a lot of consumer goods primarily
because thanks to kovid factories
overseas have been shot or have slowed
down considerably take for instance
bicycles there has been a massive bike
shortage over the last couple of years
thanks in large part to lock downs and
slow downs disrupting bike production in
china where roughly 90
of all bikes sold in the us are produced
meanwhile demand for bikes soared as
shoppers tried to stay active during
lockdowns meaning that just a few months
into the pandemic we were already seeing
stories like this bike shops across the
country now seeing skyrocketing demand
and supplies dwindling in albuquerque
new mexico this is actually the only one
we have right at the moment and in new
york city have you ever seen a bike
shortage like this before no never i'm
selling way more
pink and purple to guys
because they're just like whatever
doesn't matter what color it is that's
it is what it is it's a bike it's true
the bike shortage even broke down gender
stereotypes but interestingly
interestingly while pink and purple
bikes attracted a new male demographic
penny farthing bikes maintained their
traditional customer base fancy
mustachioed perverts
all of which helps explain why last year
the average retail price of bike
products was up 43
compared to 2019 which means essentially
one thing if you are the sort of person
who stayed active and exercised during
lockdown inflation is your fault and
you're a terrible terrible person
the point is inflation truly was a
perfect storm going into the year and it
seems like everything that's happened
since then has only made it worse when
biden said inflation is largely the
fault of putin that is clearly not true
inflation was happening before putin
even invaded ukraine so that's just not
how time works
what is true though is that putin
definitely exacerbated the problem the
invasion of ukraine greatly impacted
food and fuel prices as the world cut
off its oil purchases from russia
driving gas prices which were already
rising up to outrageous levels perhaps
best summed up by this guy
but i just got a brand new phone i just
got a new car my first car
now i see what you [ __ ] are
talking about with these gas prices my
[ __ ] was on empty i put 20 bucks in the
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] tank look at this
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
this is what 20 [ __ ] dollars gets me
are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah
if i had to bet i'd say 80 percent of a
gas station employee's job right now is
to talk people down from exactly this
situation
the other 20 is as always tracking down
some of the bluest drinks you've ever
seen now is it a good idea to sell those
in the same store where you sell
antifreeze not for me to say so
putin invading ukraine didn't start this
inflationary cycle but it is making it
worse and the same can be said of
corporate greed it is absolutely true
that some companies are taking advantage
of this environment to drive up prices
and they're getting record profits in
return and that is infuriating but
most economists will tell you that's not
what caused inflation in the first place
after all it's not like corporations
only just got greedy in the last two
years
companies will shamelessly profiteer the
exact same way that a dog will make an
absolute meal out of its own ball sack
if left to its own devices that's
unfortunately just what it's going to do
so to recap rising prices are due to a
ton of factors a pandemic a stimulus
change spending patterns supply chain
issues the war in ukraine to name just a
few and anyone loudly saying that one
thing is the course of inflation is
either lying or has absolutely no idea
what they're talking about and the fact
is whichever combination of things got
us into this mess the entity that many
are looking to to get us out of it is
the federal reserve one of its key duty
is to keep an eye out for things that
can destabilize the economy like
inflation and control it by raising and
lowering interest rates very basically
the fed can increase how much it costs
for banks to borrow money a cost that
they then pass along to businesses and
consumers through higher rates on things
like mortgages and credit cards and the
higher the interest rates the less
inclined people and businesses will be
to borrow and the more inclined they'll
be to save essentially the fed can
indirectly influence how much people are
spending so when it comes to the demand
side of the economy they have some real
power here and the fact is in this
current crisis it did arguably take too
long for the fed to raise interest rates
that's something that its chairman
jerome powell basically admitted at a
congressional hearing in march just
listen to him explain that the fed
initially saw early signs of inflation
as being due to a temporary supply shock
that would simply resolve itself
what the textbook says is
the shock's going to come and it's going
to go and and you shouldn't react to it
hindsight says we should have moved
earlier and and that that turned out to
be wrong not not maybe conceptually
wrong but it's just taking so much
longer for the supply side to heal than
we thought yeah he's right the standard
textbook of economics says that if there
is a supply shock you let it resolve
itself organically unfortunately and in
fairness to the fed the pandemic was
totally unprecedented so the standard
textbook just didn't apply in fact the
only textbook applicable to this
situation was oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the
whole world shut down what do we do oh
god oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it is not like the fed was alone in
calling this wrong most economists
thought inflation would go away on its
own and some of the loudest voices on
wall street were arguing against the fed
raising interest rates because they too
thought that inflation would be
transitory for instance here is jim
cramer the answer to the question what
if a garbage can full of cocaine and
business school pamphlets wish to be a
real boy
making that very argument in november of
last year the bottom line i don't think
pal needs to slam the brakes on the
economy despite what you hear from the
inflation nieces and the media
the weight of the evidence is finally
going pal's way team transitory is going
to win i say stop freaking about
inflation okay setting aside the fact
that he's speaking with an intensity
level there best described as patti
lupone admonishing a rude audience
member it's pretty clear that this clip
much like jim cramer himself has not
aged very well because here he was just
six months later doing a full 180 with a
very different tone i think that pal may
not understand we got to break this we
got to break it now because this was the
week where you realized that it is just
inflamed and it is not going away
uh and i i was i was just kind of just
i
i looked i was shocked
i just didn't know that it was as bad as
it is it's in every aisle the
inflation's in every aisle
wow that was a pretty dramatic
turnaround he went from loudly
unconcerned about rising prices to
full-blown inflation easter in a matter
of months and quick question what
exactly is going on with this expression
right here that is not the face you make
when you're concerned about inflation
that's the face you make when you're
watching a giraffe give birth
the fact is a lot of smart people and
jim cramer read this situation wrong and
there isn't really a road map for what
to do next as one wall street journal
columnist has said economic models that
worked for decades broke down during the
pandemic and alternatives have yet to
emerge now one thing that would really
help is if we knew the extent to which
this is a supply or a demand problem if
it's more about too much money or not
enough stuff because if it is too much
money the fed can impact that pretty
easily what they'd want to do is raise
interest rates significantly enough to
curb spending and slow growth but not so
aggressively that it would then trigger
a painful recession but if it's about
not enough stuff instead if the major
issues are things like supply chain
disruptions the effect the fed can have
is drastically reduced because the fed
can't stop the war in ukraine or open
factories that in china that are closed
due to covid i suppose jerome powell
could lead an army of economist into
luhansk
but i'm not sure anyone wants to see
that and historically that hasn't been
the fed's role so the question of
whether inflation is caused more by
supply or demand basically determines
how much influence the fed has to
improve things unfortunately even
economists don't really agree on which
is the bigger driver here i mean the
truth is inflation may not be fully
within our control right now which isn't
to say that biden hasn't been out there
promising to combat it and showing
empathy for americans who are struggling
sometimes in the weirdest way possible i
want every american to know that i'm
taking inflation uh
very seriously and it's my top for
domestic priority i know you got to be
frustrated
i know
i can taste it no no no no no no no no
never say that again
that may have been the single grossest
thing i've ever heard come out of joe
biden's mouth and that is saying a lot
because i've heard the stuff that he
used to say in the 1970s but but to be
fair i do get why biden is taking this
approach americans view inflation as the
top problem facing the u.s ahead of the
midterm elections ahead of every other
calamity facing the country including
ezra miller and there is an argument for
trying to raise public confidence once
an inflationary cycle starts simply the
expectation of it can keep inflation
going for instance as the cost of living
rises workers might demand higher wages
to cover that which in turn raises the
cost of labor leading businesses to
charge higher prices leading to still
more inflation it's basically a vicious
cycle that is why the worse our
inflation expectations are the worse it
can get and that may help explain why
the fed albeit late is now taking some
big steps it recently enacted the
biggest increase to interest rates since
1994 and it's all but certain that it
will raise them again next week
meanwhile jerome powell has been trying
to reassure people that the fed has
things under control although he has
also notably gone from talking about
trying to engineer a soft landing for
the economy to something slightly
different
so i would say there's a there's a you
know there are a number of plausible
paths
to having a soft or as i've said
soft-ish landing oh
also we're aiming for a soft-ish landing
now are we jerome the thing is ish isn't
exactly the most reassuring suffix to
hear when you're discussing something so
serious there was a huge difference
between the surgeon telling you the
surgery went well and it went well ish
and look i don't know where things are
going to go from here exactly i am not a
monetary policy wonk even though my
clothing glasses haircut and general
vibe which strongly beg to differ
although for what it's worth there have
been some small encouraging developments
recently among other things gas prices
have been dropping and long-term
inflation expectations recently ticked
down after the fed's intervention most
economists now expect this wave of
inflation to pass in a year or 18 months
although that is by no means certain and
importantly that's an incredibly long
time for those suffering the most
because for all of our discussion
tonight of supply and demand curves it
is really important to remember that
inflation's effects are anything but
abstract for those that it's hitting the
hardest like this woman describing
shopping with her kids they see it you
know like when we're when i'm in line
and i'm like you know calculating in my
head and looking at my groceries right
like like literally like i have my
calculator out like doing the tax and
like what is this gonna come to and or
i'm putting things back as we get closer
in line you know um
you know my oldest daughter is like
looking at me and then like she's
putting something back and like it just
it just you know breaks your heart a
little bit of course kids shouldn't have
to worry about putting food back on the
shelves because they can't afford it
kids should do what they are meant to do
at the grocery store go over to the big
bin of rubber balls that are
inexplicably sold there and cause
absolute mayhem
so the next year is likely to be very
hard for a lot of people which is why
what we should definitely be doing right
now is helping them one of the best ways
to help low-income families would be to
pass a refundable child tax credit for
those who need it and i know that that
might be hard especially in an
atmosphere where government spending is
being blamed for fueling inflation but
it could be narrowly targeted while also
fully offset with higher taxes on higher
earners we could also expand rental
assistance something economists say
would have a minimal impact on driving
inflation further up while also keeping
people in their homes look things are
obviously pretty bad right now families
are struggling penguins are pissed and
jim cramer looks like he just [ __ ]
himself
and there is still a lot of uncertainty
here but there are there are also two
things that we do know for sure one it's
going to take a difficult combination of
monetary policy supply chain recovery
and time to bring supply and demand back
into alignment and two that if everyone
does win the lottery in the future and
does suddenly want some frog statues i
just made the smartest investment of all
time
i'm the warren buffett of frogs
you